rené mazet
[Musique]
ça va encore est une victoire encore une
victoire pour sert il
certains jeux franchement oui
berné il est fier mais qui viennent
on va prendre
tu as aussi barré
il sera meilleur si j'étais pêcheur le
prénom du producteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la loi
[Musique]
attaqué pour
c'est un génie se vaccine des années
elle sortait de chez elle elle est
encore fait entre sortira car elle est
en train de faire une femme l'oubli à
vos frères avec un capteur pour ce soir
mais là où on arrête comme ça j'en ai
les séries boris est ce que tu peux nous
faire une petite démonstration pour vous
montrer que c'est hyper simple n'a pas
avancé
ben oui j'ai un bon boris soit tu sais
pas tu le fais souvent mais c'est la
première fois que tu fais non ça fait
plusieurs années
on va dire que c'est la première fois
que je fais on va la refaire
bon il s'apprend avant que tu le fais
oui c'est le coût n'est pas du bon boris
allez c'est parti bord ils sont donc
avant tu fais quasiment boris regardez
c'est très simple il va aller chercher
le billet vous connaissez voilà il ya
une échelle non
voilà voilà voilà
bravo bobos mais c'est pour vous montrer
que c'est assez simple voilà normalement
il n'y a pas de souci
voilà à les remercier
par sens
[Applaudissements]
ça devient bon délire
[Musique]
allez on y va démarrer isabelle fait un
service nettement c'est pas de là dedans
mais c'est déjà de faire c'est de
tanches
attention c'est parti allez c'est parti
et on va te chronométrés après tu vas
voir ça ne fait pas d'eux de ce qu'elle
fait de mauvais tours huawei les
trouveront tensions dans sa quatre vingt
dix à katia banon mais mes toiles à mes
toiles ahmed el arabi
[Rires]
ça m'a dit bon ami et précieux c'est une
catastrophe
mais l'allemagne où ça avec les doigts
francesca nivernais jean michel mr et
lidé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
allez choisir la personne à qui vous
allez prendre de l'argent attendu à la
fin jeudi
chaque sommes donc sera retiré et
ajouter une cagnotte globale combinant
ne bougeait pas 50 balles à matthieu
delormeau noté mettez s'accommode dans
la cagnotte
oui bon ça au kayak ayala est une fibre
il pas dit pourquoi si oui ou non il est
emporté par le 2 ans du psg 2 2 au 3 ou
3 il est pas mal et il est bien tiré
attention pour les bottés c'est vous
hashtag gilles verdez attentive et quand
l'attention aux quatre c'est parti la
maladie au cat et d'autres qui gagne
aucun écho si le mais là il tout le
public est invité aux spectateurs
mazembe tp mazembe
[Applaudissements]